Musique de tension
...
-C'est une bombe.
C'est une vraie bombe éditoriale
comme il n'en a pas beaucoup existé,
à mon avis, au 20e siècle.
Elle est presque unique.
Elle va totalement bouleverser
le rapport des gens
au communisme
et à la réalité soviétique.
...
-C'est un livre extraordinaire,
la découverte d'une autre histoire.
A l'école, à l'université,
on nous apprenait
une version de l'histoire
et soudain, on découvrait
qu'il y en avait une autre
dont on ne nous parlait pas,
à laquelle nous devions accéder
par nous-mêmes.
C'était la véritable histoire
de notre pays.
...
-Pour que les gens comprennent,
c'est des centaines de milliers
de personnes qui se mettent
à lire ce livre
au même moment, et...
des polémiques d'une violence
complètement folle
qui se déclenchent
sur un objet littéraire.
...
-C'est un récit
de sa lutte, de sa lutte
avec le pouvoir,
avec les confrères,
avec les autorités,
avec lui-même,
pour trouver le courage,
et c'est magnifique.
...
Musique mélancolique
-Quelques mois avant sa mort,
Alexandre Soljénitsyne
nous avait raconté
comment était née en secret
"L'archipel du goulag".
Il parle en russe.
...
Un immense récit
pour décrire ce que fut
le système concentrationnaire
en Union soviétique,
de 1918 à 1956.
...
Un livre unique,
nourri de l'expérience
de Soljénitsyne dans les camps
et du témoignage de 227 Zeks,
les détenus du goulag.
...
Nous avions rencontré celles et ceux
que Soljénitsyne avait
appelés les invisibles.
Prenant des risques,
ces femmes et ces hommes,
aujourd'hui disparus,
avaient aidé l'écrivain à mener
à bien son travail sur l'archipel.
Dans des conditions dignes
d'un roman de John le Carré,
"L'archipel du goulag",
transformé en microfilm,
traverse le rideau de fer
pour arriver en France en 1968.
Les éditeurs Claude Durand
et Nikita Struve
n'ont plus qu'à attendre
le signal de Soljénitsyne
pour le publier.
L'histoire de ce livre
hors du commun
ne faisait que commencer.
A cette époque,
Yves Hamant,
jeune agrégé de russe,
vient d'être nommé professeur
à l'université.
-Nikita Struve,
un beau jour,
me fixe un rendez-vous
mystérieux dans un café,
dans le centre de Paris.
Pas à l'université,
pas à proximité d'YMCA-Press.
Et là, il me dit :
"J'ai reçu un texte,
"c'est une bombe.
"Personne ne doit
en connaître l'existence."
Il cherche un traducteur
qui puisse travailler
dans le plus grand secret.
Et j'ai eu
la légèreté d'accepter.
En même temps, je me disais :
"Soljénitsyne, il est pas pressé
de laisser publier ce livre."
Donc on a du temps, voilà.
-Derrière l'apparente
insouciance de cette fin d'été,
nous sommes
en pleine Guerre froide.
Léonid Brejnev
est à la tête de l'URSS,
et si rien
ne le laisse présager,
l'histoire de "L'archipel du goulag"
va basculer.
Elena Tchoukovskaya, Lioucha,
comme la surnommait Soljénitsyne,
était une invisible, l'une
des plus proches de l'écrivain.
Elle nous avait donné
rendez-vous chez elle
et n'avait rien oublié
de cette journée particulière.
-Je me souviens très bien,
c'était fin août.
Sous une pluie terrible
arrive de Leningrad mon ami Etkin.
Il me raconte qu'il est allé
à un enterrement
auquel il avait été convié
sans même savoir qui était mort.
Et là, il apprend que c'était
Elizaveta Denisovna.
On a essayé de savoir
ce qui s'était passé.
Même s'il était impossible
de demander quoi que ce soit
par téléphone, on ne comprenait
vraiment pas ce qui s'était passé.
-Elizaveta était au coeur
du dispositif clandestin
mis au point par Soljénitsyne.
Elle avait tapé à la machine
"L'archipel du goulag"
et en avait gardé un exemplaire.
Arrêtée par le KGB, Elizaveta
subit des interrogatoires
jour et nuit, et finit par avouer
en détenir une copie.
...
Libérée,
elle rentre chez elle
et se suicide.
-On l'a appris...
En fait, c'est une longue histoire.
C'est tout à fait par hasard.
La chose a été sue, à Leningrad.
Et là-bas, grâce à une personne
de confiance,
nous avons été avertis
que le livre avait été saisi.
-Le manuscrit est désormais
aux mains du KGB.
...
-Il a tout de suite décidé
qu'il ne fallait plus rien différer.
Il fallait le publier.
Ca s'est passé le 1er septembre,
et le 5,
Alexandre a fait savoir en France
qu'il fallait publier "L'archipel".
Musique haletante
...
-En décembre 73, ils l'ont publié
en russe, et ça a été un boum.
...
-Le livre est édité à Paris
par la librairie historique
de l'immigration russe,
YMCA-Press.
Aussitôt, les articles
se multiplient
à la une des journaux
du monde entier.
Musique à suspense
A suivre les réactions
dans la presse,
on pourrait penser
que "L'archipel du goulag" est
le premier livre qui révèle
l'existence des camps
en Union soviétique.
-Ce n'est pas tout à fait vrai.
On pouvait savoir beaucoup de choses
sur les camps en Union soviétique.
Je suis tombée un jour
sur un livre en français
concernant les îles Solovki.
Il s'agissait des premiers camps
dans les années 1920.
A l'époque,
de nombreux groupes de gauche,
dans toute l'Europe, connaissaient
l'existence de ces camps
parce que certains de
leurs camarades y étaient détenus.
On pouvait lire des publications
sur ces camps à Berlin et à Paris
et ils étaient connus.
Musique sombre
...
-Entre 1918 et 1930,
j'ai comptabilisé
au moins une trentaine de livres
parus dans le monde entier
concernant
les méthodes d'emprisonnement,
la répression,
les camps qui venaient
de s'ouvrir, etc.
Et donc, il est évident
qu'on savait des choses.
Sauf que, et c'est ça
qui a joué beaucoup,
est arrivée
la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Donc à côté du nazisme,
on a oublié le côté goulag.
-Beaucoup de gens
ne voulaient rien savoir.
Le sujet les mettait mal à l'aise
pour de nombreuses raisons,
bonnes ou mauvaises :
l'Union soviétique
avait été notre alliée
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
il était gênant de dire
que nous avions détruit un monstre
avec l'aide d'un autre.
...
-Et puis,
jusqu'à "L'archipel du goulag",
ça a fait un boum.
Tout d'un coup, on découvre
des choses qui avaient été oubliées.
Pas vraiment oubliées,
parce que ça existait,
et on le savait,
mais on n'en parlait pas.
...
-En décembre 1973,
Soljénitsyne n'est pas à Moscou,
auprès de sa femme Natalia.
Il se trouve à la datcha
de son ami l'écrivain
Korneï Tchoukovski.
-C'est là-bas
qu'il se trouvait ce jour-là,
et c'est là qu'il a entendu,
à la BBC,
que le premier tome
de "L'archipel" en russe
avait été publié en France.
Il espérait que le livre sorte
pour le Noël orthodoxe
le 7 janvier, comme convenu,
mais il est sorti un peu plus tôt.
Alors il est parti aussitôt
pour venir ici,
dans cet appartement, chez moi,
et toute la soirée
a été une fête.
Musique mélancolique
-Quelques jours plus tard,
les premiers exemplaires
de "L'archipel du goulag"
parviennent
clandestinement à Moscou.
...
-Nous en avons reçu deux
en même temps,
par un canal ou par deux canaux
différents.
Et par qui concrètement ?
Je ne peux pas vous le dire,
parce qu'à l'époque, on gardait
une certaine discrétion.
Celui qui n'avait pas
à être au courant,
on ne lui disait rien
de superflu.
-De son côté, l'organe central
du Parti Communiste soviétique,
la Pravda, ne tarde pas à réagir
et dénonce les "calomnies"
de Soljénitsyne qui servent
les forces
de la réaction impérialiste.
La confrontation
s'annonce violente.
-Savoir si j'allais
en sortir vainqueur,
je n'en avais aucune certitude.
Mais le fait
que j'avais lancé un livre
qui allait leur porter un coup
et qui, avec toute sa force,
allait lutter contre eux,
ça, je le comprenais.
-Rapidement,
le KGB informe
le Politburo,
l'organe suprême du pouvoir,
du danger du livre.
Le compte rendu d'une réunion
au Kremlin témoigne
de la réaction de Léonid Brejnev.
"Il s'agit d'un grossier pamphlet
antisoviétique.
"Soljénitsyne s'en est pris
à ce que nous avons
"de plus sacré, à Lénine,
à notre régime soviétique.
"Il faut aujourd'hui décider
de ce qu'il convient de faire."
-Alexandre Soljénitsyne
est en Allemagne de l'Ouest.
Il avait été appréhendé hier
à son domicile de Moscou.
Il a été expulsé aujourd'hui
par les autorités de son pays.
Le Kremlin a eu recours
à une mesure sans précédent
depuis près d'un demi-siècle :
Soljénitsyne a subi
le même sort
que Léon Trotski en 1929.
-L'arrestation puis l'expulsion
de l'écrivain
renforcent considérablement
en Occident
l'intérêt pour Soljénitsyne
et "L'archipel du goulag".
-Les gens sont prêts à entendre
certains types d'informations
à certains moments
et ne sont pas prêts
à d'autres moments.
Les gens n'étaient pas prêts
à entendre la vérité
sur l'Union soviétique
dans les années 40
parce que la guerre a été gagnée
par une alliance avec Staline.
25 ou 30 ans plus tard,
c'était très différent.
C'était un moment où il était clair
que l'Union soviétique
et l'Europe de l'Est étaient
un système d'oppression.
-Bien entendu, il y a aussi
l'aspect artificiel du choc :
"On savait pas
que le socialisme
"libérateur de l'humanité
avait créé un bagne."
Ca tient pas debout.
Evidemment, si on veut pas savoir,
on sait pas.
Aujourd'hui aussi, si vous voulez,
si on veut pas savoir
qu'il y a des gens affamés
dans le Darfour,
on le sait pas.
On fait son petit gueuleton
tranquille.
Si on le sait, on tombe
dans une certaine intranquillité,
et Soljénitsyne nous mène,
de façon profonde,
je pense,
à une intranquillité...
qui n'est pas du tout idéologique,
qui est une intranquillité...
philosophique.
-"L'archipel du goulag" commence
à ébranler les certitudes.
Pourtant, on en sait peu
sur ce livre,
qui n'a pas encore été traduit.
On parle de témoignages
que des victimes du goulag
ont confiés à Soljénitsyne.
-J'ai compris alors
que le destin m'envoyait
ce dont j'avais besoin.
"L'archipel" est venu à moi
à travers ces gens.
J'ai par la suite identifié
les plus importants d'entre eux,
ceux que je considère
comme les véritables co-auteurs
de "L'archipel".
Bien sûr, ils ne comprenaient pas
ce que je faisais,
pourquoi j'avais besoin d'eux.
Personne n'était au courant
de mon projet, personne.
Eux, c'est avec leurs émotions,
leurs sentiments,
qu'ils me donnaient
ces informations.
Je les recueillais avec plaisir
tout en me demandant
comment les intégrer
à la structure du livre.
-"Fastenko
était le plus alerte
"de la cellule,
bien que vu son âge, il fût
"le seul à ne pouvoir
escompter survivre
"à la détention
et recouvrer un jour la liberté.
"Il me disait en me prenant
par les épaules : "'C'est une chose
"que de tenir pour la vérité.
"'Toi, pour elle,
tu te fais détenir.'
"Ou bien il m'apprenait sa chanson,
une chanson de bagnard.
"'S'il doit nous échoir
un jour de mourir,
"'au fond d'une mine
ou d'une prison,
"'cela se réfléchira sans faillir
sur les générations
"qui resteront.'"
Je le crois,
et puissent ces pages aider
cette croyance à s'accomplir.
-C'était une collection
de témoignages,
plus de 235 témoignages
qui ont été rassemblés
par Soljénitsyne.
C'est une vision absolument globale
du système concentrationnaire,
de l'arrestation, des tortures,
de la vie dans les camps,
des gens qui sortent des camps
et comment ils sont considérés...
C'est un tableau global
de la chose,
et ça, personne
ne l'avait vraiment fait.
Quand on lit le livre,
les trois tomes, on est...
Excusez-moi, on passe
sous un rouleau compresseur.
On passe
On peut pas sortir indemne
de cette lecture.
Moi, j'en suis pas sorti indemne.
-Il n'écrit pas seulement
sur les camps.
Il a écrit sur les camps,
sur la guerre, sur la révolution.
Il écrit sur la façon
dont l'homme se comporte
dans des situations extrêmes.
Ces situations extrêmes
sont de diverses natures.
Cela peut être la guerre,
une maladie mortelle
ou la révolution.
C'est précisément de ça dont
il a parlé dans tous ses livres,
de la manière dont
les gens réagissent,
dont ils se comportent
dans ces situations extrêmes.
-Soljénitsyne ne fait pas
que décrire le goulag,
il ne fait pas que décrire
la vie dans un camp.
Soljénitsyne...
Il s'intéresse à toute la machinerie
qui va conduire...
des hommes libres à l'état de Zeks,
c'est-à-dire
de prisonniers de camps
de concentration.
-"Tout nouvel entrant,
après avoir joué du piano
"à la section spéciale du camp,
"c'est-à-dire après y avoir donné
ses empreintes digitales,
"se passait autour du cou un fil
supportant une planchette.
"Sur la planchette,
on composait son numéro,
"et le photographe
de la section spéciale
"le photographiait ainsi harnaché.
"Ces photos,
"toutes ces photos sont encore bien
conservées quelques part.
"Nous les verrons bien un jour."
-L'historien Alexandre Daniel,
dissident
à l'époque soviétique,
est l'un des responsables
de l'association Memorial,
qui travaille
sur la mémoire du goulag.
Son père, l'écrivain Iouli Daniel,
a été l'un des accusés
du premier grand procès
de la dissidence en 1965.
Sa mère,
Larissa Bogoraz,
a été condamnée à quatre ans
de relégation en Sibérie
pour avoir manifesté en 1968
contre l'intervention soviétique
en Tchécoslovaquie.
-Soljénitsyne a réussi à faire
quelque chose d'extraordinaire.
Il a réussi la fusion
de deux courants de la mémoire :
l'analyse de la terreur
par l'intelligentsia
et la mémoire populaire
de la terreur,
c'est-à-dire la mémoire d'en bas,
les témoignages directs
d'une quantité de gens
sur la terreur,
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
"oral history",
l'histoire orale.
Musique mélancolique
...
-Cette structure générale,
les raisons
pour lesquelles les camps
ont été créés,
comment ils ont été créés,
comment se comportaient
les gardiens et les prisonniers,
la fameuse division
entre les prisonniers politiques
et les prisonniers criminels
et leurs relations,
le sort des femmes
et des enfants,
- il y en avait aussi
dans les camps -
tout cela,
il l'a bien compris
sans avoir accès aux archives
ni aux informations officielles.
C'est un document
tout à fait remarquable.
*-L'Union soviétique...
-Du côté du Parti
Communiste Français,
la réaction face à la publication
de "L'archipel du goulag"
est parfaitement conforme
à la ligne du Kremlin.
*-Hier soir, Georges Marchais
a évoqué l'affaire Soljénitsyne.
-Dans ce livre,
l'auteur, russe, évoque des faits
que la Parti Communiste
de l'Union soviétique
a lui-même dénoncé publiquement
il y a près de 20 ans
et auxquels il a mis un terme.
Mais le livre de Soljénitsyne
constitue en même temps
une agression si violente,
si haineuse contre le socialisme...
-En 74, le Parti Communiste
commence à être un peu
sur le déclin.
Il a quand même été un parti
qui avait plus de 25 % des voix
à la Libération, il ne les a plus.
Mais il est encore puissant.
Et il réagit...
Il y a eu une façon,
je dirais frontale,
qui a consisté à dire :
"C'est une nouvelle campagne
antisoviétique,
"ça n'est pas intéressant,
c'est même lamentable
"qu'aujourd'hui encore,
on puisse
"revenir à de tels propos."
Et puis il est capable de dire :
"On connaît tout cela.
"Vous n'apportez rien de nouveau,
monsieur Soljénitsyne.
"Notre parti a condamné,
"il y a déjà une vingtaine d'années,
le goulag."
Musique à suspense
-En fait, le Parti Communiste
Français à cette époque
n'a jamais rien condamné.
Il faudra attendre 1977
pour qu'il reconnaisse
l'existence du fameux
rapport Khrouchtchev,
présenté en 1956
au 20e congrès
du Parti Communiste
de l'Union Soviétique.
Ce rapport dénonçait le culte
de la personnalité de Staline,
mais sans évoquer
les crimes de masse
estimés
à 15 ou 20 millions de morts.
-Le rapport Khrouchtchev
ne concernait
que le Parti Communiste
et les dirigeants
du parti injustement condamnés.
Il ne décrivait pas l'ensemble
du phénomène du stalinisme
ou du système soviétique,
qui s'est poursuivi
sous Khrouchtchev.
Il y avait encore
des camps de prisonniers
sous le régime
de Khrouchtchev.
Lorsque le système du goulag
a fini par disparaître,
on a continué à arrêter les gens
pour des raisons politiques.
-"'Cela ne se reproduira plus.'
"'Gloire au parti !'
"'Cela ne se reproduira plus.'
Ah, les malins !
"Ah, les maîtres plâtriers.
"Puisque cela ne se reproduira plus,
"il va de soi qu'aujourd'hui,
cela n'existe déjà plus.
"Exclu pour l'avenir,
"et bien entendu,
inconnu dans le présent.
-Soljénitsyne fait remarquer
que le goulag
commence non pas
avec Staline,
mais avec Lénine.
Lui considère que cette réalité
concentrationnaire
est consubstantielle
du communisme.
-Affirmation insupportable
pour les communistes,
comme le souligne Boris Joukov,
un représentant du Kremlin interrogé
par la télévision française.
-Pour moi,
c'est mon ennemi personnel.
Pour les Soviétiques aussi.
Maintenant,
il veut revenir là-dessus,
mais pas pour condamner une fois
de plus cette chose-là,
mais pour dire que c'est le système
qui est responsable,
que c'est Lénine qui a installé
les camps de concentration.
C'est insensé
parce que tout le monde sait
que Lénine
était un grand homme,
vraiment un grand homme,
et un noble d'esprit.
C'était un grand homme politique.
-Reconnaître que c'est sous Lénine
que le goulag a commencé,
c'est une ligne rouge
que le Parti Communiste Français
ne veut pas franchir.
Musique de tension animée
Le 1er juin 1974,
la parution en français
de "L'archipel du goulag"
se produit dans un contexte
politique inédit à gauche.
-Il y avait une gauche
qui voulait absolument se rassembler
pour prendre le pouvoir.
Après des années de gaullisme
et les années Pompidou,
ils voulaient le pouvoir.
Il y avait un programme commun
mis en place
avec les socialistes
et les communistes.
Evidemment, on était
dans un contexte particulier.
Au moment où "L'archipel"
est publié
en début 74,
on est en pleine
élection électorale.
Nous avons un candidat principal
à gauche, François Mitterrand.
-Naturellement,
Mitterrand ne cherche pas
à provoquer le Parti Communiste.
Après tout,
l'Union Soviétique, c'est loin.
Son désir...
de réussir
la présidentielle,
il est au contraire
très présent.
Mitterrand est prudent.
-On est dans une bataille politique
dans laquelle l'Union Soviétique,
les camps, le goulag...
Ca n'existe pas.
On est sur une autre planète.
Musique grave
-De son côté, Yves Hamant,
le premier traducteur
de "L'archipel du goulag",
est nommé attaché culturel
à l'ambassade de France à Moscou.
-Avant de partir,
Nikita Struve me demande :
"Maintenant que vous serez
sur place, à Moscou,
"est-ce que vous accepteriez
de servir de relais
"entre Soljénitsyne et son épouse
et puis leurs amis ?"
Il s'agissait essentiellement
de transmettre du courrier,
des lettres,
pour maintenir le contact.
Tout ça se faisant bien entendu
à l'insu de mon ambassade.
Ca va sans dire.
-Dans un Moscou digne
d'un film d'espionnage,
Yves Hamant devient un invisible
au service de Soljénitsyne.
Avec lui et beaucoup d'autres,
"L'archipel"
ne tarde pas à rentrer
clandestinement en URSS,
malgré la surveillance du KGB.
La romancière
Lioudmila Oulitskaya
appartient à une famille
marquée par la répression
et les camps.
Elle vit aujourd'hui
en exil à Berlin.
-Nous avons commencé
à recevoir des livres
grâce à des étrangers de passage
qui les faisaient passer
par leur ambassade,
par la valise diplomatique.
Nous avions ainsi accès
à ce genre de littérature.
Musique mélancolique
-C'était risqué
vis-à-vis de mon ambassade.
La devise, c'était :
"Ne nous brouillons pas
avec les Soviets."
En revanche, les Américains
faisaient cela ouvertement.
On savait qu'à l'ambassade
des Etats-Unis,
il y avait des caisses
de livres en russe,
des livres interdits.
Et ça...
le personnel de l'ambassade
des Etats-Unis
le faisait ouvertement et eux,
ils avaient tout à fait l'accord
de leurs autorités.
-Une guerre d'influence
que confirme l'ancien directeur
de la CIA Robert Gates.
-Vous savez, c'est ce que nous
avons fait en Union soviétique,
durant la Guerre froide.
Avec très peu de technologies,
nous avons fait passer
des millions de livres
comme "L'archipel du goulag".
Musique intrigante
-Alexandre Podrabinek a été
une grande figure de la dissidence.
Deux fois jugé pour diffamation
du régime soviétique,
il a passé cinq ans et demi
en prison dans un camp
et en relégation en Sibérie.
Il vit toujours à Moscou.
-J'ai lu "L'archipel du goulag"
quelques mois après sa publication.
Il a tout de suite commencé
à arriver
en Union soviétique en 1974.
D'ailleurs, avec un ami,
nous en avons fait
plusieurs copies.
On nous avait passé
un exemplaire publié à Paris.
Ce qu'on appelait
le "Tamizdat".
On l'a photographié
et on en a tiré
sept exemplaires.
L'endroit où nous avons fait ça,
ce n'était plus un appartement,
c'était une maison de fous.
Il y avait des photos partout,
des piles de photos sur la table.
Et dans tout l'appartement,
ça sentait le révélateur
et le fixateur.
A l'époque,
on faisait tout nous-mêmes.
Musique grave
...
-Je n'étais pas seule
à le lire.
Nous étions plusieurs.
C'était des feuilles tapées
à la machine à écrire
qui n'étaient pas attachées
les unes aux autres.
On lisait une feuille
et on la passait
à quelqu'un d'autre.
Ce n'est pas seulement "L'archipel"
que nous avons lu
de cette façon,
mais aussi d'autres livres,
de cet auteur
et de d'autres auteurs.
Les cuisines, chez nous,
elles n'étaient pas grandes.
Mais c'est dans ces cuisines
pleines de monde
qu'on se retrouvait
et qu'on lisait.
C'était une particularité très
intéressante de la vie soviétique.
Nous vivions en petites
communautés bien soudées.
C'est ce qu'on appelait
les cuisines de Moscou.
Musique pesante
...
-Olga Sédakova est poétesse
et essayiste.
Son oeuvre d'abord diffusée
dans les circuits du samizdat
à l'époque soviétique
a ensuite été publiée
à l'étranger.
Elle habite toujours à Moscou.
-C'était une édition
sur du papier très fin,
en un seul tome.
Les étudiants
se le passaient entre eux
en exigeant qu'on leur rende
un jour ou deux après.
On donnait ce livre
pour très peu de temps.
C'est comme ça
que j'ai découvert ce livre.
On lui avait donné un surnom.
On l'appelait "le gâteau"
parce qu'il était de petit format.
On avait trouvé une boîte de gâteau
dans laquelle on le cachait
pour le passer à un ami.
Au téléphone on disait :
"Viens prendre le gâteau."
C'était nos méthodes
de conspiration.
Musique intrigante
...
-Je pense
qu'il n'y a pas un pays au monde,
à aucune époque,
où la parole imprimée
avait une telle valeur.
Pour avoir lu un tel livre,
on pouvait perdre son travail.
Ce qui m'est arrivé, d'ailleurs.
Ou même être envoyé dans un camp,
comme cela est arrivé à d'autres.
C'était vraiment
une occupation très dangereuse.
-"Ivanovo, ce n'est pas
une prison de transit très renommée.
"Mais interrogez donc ceux qui ont
été enfermés durant l'hiver 37-38.
"La cellule 21 devait
abriter 20 détenus.
"Or, ils étaient 323.
"On ne distribuait pas
la nourriture à chacun des détenus,
"mais par groupes de 10.
"Si l'un des 10 mourait,
"on le fourrait sous le châlit
et on l'y gardait,
"jusqu'à ce que le cadavre empestât.
"Ainsi, pouvait-on continuer
à toucher sa ration
"pendant quelque temps."
-En général,
on allait en prison,
pas pouvoir avoir fait
circuler ce genre de livres,
mais pour les avoir fabriqués.
Le fait que l'on est lu
un livre comme ça,
ça pouvait encore passer.
Mais si quelqu'un se mettait
à le reproduire,
notamment
avec des moyens techniques,
on faisait tout
pour lui mettre la main dessus.
Là, les gens allaient en prison.
-Régulièrement,
la presse clandestine dissidente
rend compte d'arrestations
et de condamnations
pour avoir reproduit ou diffusé
"L'archipel du goulag".
-Mon grand-père a été envoyé
dans un camp,
à Vorkouta.
Sa femme,
la belle-mère de ma mère,
a aussi été dans les camps.
Et dans la famille de ma mère,
beaucoup de personnes
ont été victimes de la répression.
Certaines ont été exécutées.
La soeur de mon grand-père, elle,
elle a passé 20 ans
dans les camps de la Kolyma.
D'une manière générale,
je connaissais bien
tous les aspects du sujet,
mais Soljénitsyne a réussi
à créer un panorama
qui réellement couvre
toute cette période de la terreur,
de 1917 à 1953.
-L'ampleur,
l'immensité de ces crimes,
bien sûr, était quelque chose
d'inimaginable,
ce qui fait que,
d'une certaine façon,
ma vision du monde
s'est transformée,
ainsi que ma compréhension
de ce qui se passait
dans le monde
et dans notre pays.
Musique grave
...
Musique vive
-L'édition française
de "L'archipel du goulag"
arrive en librairie.
-Immense succès.
Premier tirage :
550 000 exemplaires.
En France.
Un des plus gros
que j'ai jamais connus.
Peu après,
au début de l'été,
on en était à 850 000
ou 900 000 exemplaires.
La totalité des trois volumes
en France
a fait plus de 1,2 million
d'exemplaires.
Ce sont les Français
et les Allemands
qui ont été les premiers
à le publier.
Les Américains sont venus après,
mais le livre a eu un énorme succès
aux Etats-Unis aussi.
Il a fait 3 millions d'exemplaires.
Avec 30 à 40 traductions
dans le monde,
le livre a atteint
les 10 millions d'exemplaires.
La façon dont le public
a été demandeur
dès le début,
dès le premier jour,
montre que ça venait à son heure.
-"Bien sûr,
nous ne perdions pas espoir.
"Ce que nous avions vécu
serait un jour raconté.
"Tôt ou tard, en effet,
la vérité finit par être dite
"sur tous les événements
de l'histoire,
"mais il nous semblait
que cela ne viendrait pas
"avant longtemps,
"que la plupart d'entre nous
seraient morts avant
"et qu'il faudrait que la situation
ait profondément changé.
"Moi-même qui me considérais
comme le chroniqueur de l'archipel
"et qui écrivais,
écrivais sans relâche,
"je comptais peu
voir la chose de mon vivant."
-Pour une partie
de la génération de mai 68,
la lecture
de "L'archipel du goulag"
débouche sur une véritable
prise de conscience.
-Cette génération 68,
le communisme manière soviétique,
c'était le vieux monde.
Un des slogans de 68 était
"Cours, cours, camarade,
le vieux monde est derrière toi".
Donc pour eux,
c'était le vieux monde.
Cette génération post-68
était admirative,
c'était quand même incroyable
de le penser,
parce que c'était de mal en pis,
quelque part,
de Mao, du maoïsme.
Pour eux, c'était pas un problème
d'attaquer l'Union soviétique
et de dénoncer le goulag soviétique.
-Là, il y a deux gauches
qui vont s'opposer.
Il y en a une
qui va accepter Soljénitsyne,
plus que d'accepter, d'ailleurs,
qui va devenir la partie
qui le défendra le plus
et le plus brillamment,
je pense,
et une autre partie
qui va le rejeter
et qui va pas vouloir l'entendre,
parce qu'en fait,
elle pressent que l'écouter,
l'entendre, le lire,
c'est mourir.
-Les deux jeunes intellectuels
les plus actifs
dans la défense de Soljénitsyne,
c'est André Glucksmann
et Bernard-Henri Lévy.
André Glucksmann a
une très belle formule à ce sujet :
"Les camps, c'est un bon
point de vue sur le marxisme."
C'est-à-dire que
ça nous permet de lire
la substantifique moelle
du marxisme.
-Puisque vous étiez
correspondant de L'Humanité,
vous avez renseigné
les lecteurs français
de ce qui se passait
en Union soviétique ?
Des camps de concentration ?
"Ah, on ne connaît pas
les chiffres !"
Mais bien sûr !
On ne connaît pas non plus
les chiffres
dans les fours crématoires !
-Vous n'avez rien lu
de ce que j'ai écrit.
-Ah si. Si, il y avait
une belle apologie de Lyssenko.
Lui, ses concurrents, il les mettait
dans ces camps, précisément.
-Mon père, quand il lit
"L'archipel du goulag",
c'est une révolution intérieure.
C'est...
C'est un moment fondamental.
C'est une fracture dans l'histoire,
à la fois d'une vie personnelle
et dans l'histoire collective.
-C'est ça, la philosophie...
-L'émission "La part de vérité"
nous donne une idée
de ce qu'était
le débat à l'époque.
Autour de la table, entre autres,
Michel Foucault, Maurice Clavel,
Guy Lardreau,
André Glucksmann,
et on parle de Soljénitsyne
et de "L'archipel du goulag".
-Dans les universités françaises
et dans les milieux bien,
on discute du socialisme, on discute
des moindres virgules de Marx,
tout le monde sait qu'une virgule
à droite ou à gauche,
ça détermine le sens
de l'histoire.
Cela dit, il est évident
que les mêmes gens
ne veulent pas,
et systématiquement,
ne veulent pas
lire Soljénitsyne.
-Vous savez la meilleure
qu'on entend ?
"Oh, le troisième tome du "Goulag",
que c'est long, que c'est long !"
Evidemment, 50 millions de morts,
ça fait une liste longue.
-Eh oui.
-Et dans les librairies de gauche,
ça ne se vend pas.
-C'est vraiment le basculement
d'une génération
qui a plus cru qu'aucune autre
dans le mythe révolutionnaire
et qui, tout d'un coup,
se retrouve face à "L'archipel",
et qui vit "L'archipel"
comme une déflagration intérieure
fondamentale.
-Je sais pas. Je crois que
c'est quand même assez simple.
Soljénitsyne,
c'est une philosophie.
C'est une philosophie
qui fait pas plaisir.
La grandeur de "L'archipel",
c'est qu'on y trouvera pas
une once d'illusion nulle part.
Soljénitsyne, c'est quelqu'un
qui ne ment jamais.
-Depuis leur exil,
Alexandre et Natalia Soljénitsyne
utilisent les droits d'auteur
générés par l'immense succès
de "L'archipel"
pour alimenter leur fonds d'aide
aux prisonniers politiques.
-Tous les droits d'auteur
sur ce livre,
à l'époque où j'étais encore
à l'étranger,
je les ai donnés à notre fonds.
Nous avons beaucoup aidé ici,
en Russie, en Union soviétique,
d'abord les prisonniers
qui se trouvaient alors
en détention,
et puis plus tard,
nous avons apporté notre aide
aux anciens prisonniers,
à ceux qui étaient déjà âgés,
aux invalides du goulag.
-Ce fonds d'aide
donnait aux gens la possibilité
de se sentir libres,
car ils savaient
que leurs proches et leurs familles
ne seraient pas dans la misère
si on les arrêtait,
que quelqu'un s'occuperait d'eux,
leur viendrait en aide
et ne les laisserait pas tomber.
Savoir qu'il en serait ainsi
était très important à cette époque.
-Soljénitsyne, qui s'est installé
dans le Vermont, aux Etats-Unis,
reste persuadé qu'il reviendra
un jour dans son pays.
Musique mélancolique
...
Au milieu des années 80,
Mikhaïl Gorbatchev tente,
avec la perestroïka,
une profonde réforme
du système soviétique.
Il autorise alors
une certaine liberté d'expression
dont va bénéficier Soljénitsyne.
...
-Il estimait
qu'il ne pouvait pas revenir
tant qu'on n'aurait pas publié
"L'archipel du goulag",
et cela pour une raison très simple.
D'abord, on l'a exilé
à cause de "L'archipel du goulag".
C'est cette publication
qui en a été la cause.
Deuxièmement, des gens
ont été envoyés en prison
à cause de "L'archipel",
pour avoir lu "L'archipel"
en secret.
Des gens ont été dans des camps,
et lui, il va rentrer ?
On l'a expulsé
à cause de "L'archipel"
et lui va rentrer
comme si de rien n'était ?
Non. D'abord, libérez ces gens
et publiez le livre.
-En 1989,
profitant de l'affaiblissement
de la censure à Moscou,
la revue Novy Mir publie
des extraits de "L'archipel".
-Le rédacteur en chef de Novy Mir
à l'époque, Zalyguine,
était un homme
tout à fait remarquable.
Il était prêt à faire
ce pas courageux et il l'a fait,
parce que publier "L'archipel"
écrit par un traître à la patrie,
c'était encore plus terrible
que de publier en 1962
le récit d'un petit instituteur
de la ville de Riazan.
-Plusieurs maisons d'édition
vont ensuite assurer la diffusion
de "L'archipel du goulag"
dans un plus large public.
L'Union soviétique
est alors à bout de souffle.
Elle va disparaître
deux ans plus tard.
-Quand "L'archipel du goulag"
a été imprimé chez nous
avec de gros tirages
dans les années 90,
il est apparu que ces informations
n'avaient pas sur mes compatriotes
l'effet colossal qu'elles avaient eu
sur moi à l'époque en 1974.
"L'archipel du goulag"
a sûrement modifié
la conscience de notre société,
mais pas autant que je l'attendais.
Peut-être que mes attentes
étaient exagérées.
J'avais l'impression
qu'après avoir lu ce livre,
les gens allaient aussitôt
rejeter le communisme,
le système totalitaire
et son idéologie,
mais ça ne s'est pas passé
de manière aussi radicale
que je l'avais pensé.
-Nous avions l'impression,
et beaucoup de gens
le disaient à l'époque,
qu'on souhaitait tous
simplement oublier tout cela.
Cela ne concernait pas
seulement Soljénitsyne,
mais aussi Chalamov
et toute cette thématique.
On était convaincus,
je ne sais pas pourquoi,
que tout cela était terminé à jamais
et que jamais plus
nous ne serions confrontés
à une machine de répression absolue.
Dans ces conditions,
à quoi bon tout cela ?
Nous allons vivre bien
dans ce monde nouveau.
C'était l'état d'esprit
général.
Musique triste
-Mais tout le monde
ne voulait pas oublier
ce passé.
Créée à la faveur de la perestroïka,
avec l'aide du prix Nobel
de la paix, Andreï Sakharov,
l'association Memorial
se donne pour mission de préserver
la mémoire des victimes
des répressions politiques
en URSS.
...
Elle fouille les archives,
met au jour des charniers
et, au fil des années,
dresse une liste nominative
inachevée de 3 millions
de victimes.
Une manière de poursuivre
le travail entamé
dans "L'archipel du goulag".
Comme il l'avait prédit,
Soljénitsyne
est de retour en Russie.
En juillet 1994,
il atterrit à Magadan,
la capitale
de la Kolyma en Sibérie.
-Je m'incline
devant la terre de la Kolyma
où reposent des centaines
de milliers,
sinon des millions
de nos compatriotes suppliciés.
-Dans les années 90
souffle un vent de liberté.
Il n'y a pas que le retour
de Soljénitsyne.
Memorial travaille librement.
C'est après l'arrivée
au pouvoir de Vladimir Poutine
en 2000 que tout change.
La réécriture
de l'Histoire
devient un enjeu politique.
-Il a commencé à limiter
l'accès aux archives
à ce qui pouvait
être publié en Russie.
Ca l'intéresse
depuis longtemps.
Le refus de reconnaître
plus longtemps
l'histoire qui a été acceptée
au cours des 30 dernières années,
Poutine l'utilise
et dit aux Russes :
"Attention,
cela pourrait revenir."
-Il n'y a pas que la difficulté
d'accès aux archives,
Memorial fait l'objet
de perquisitions.
La justice enquête
sur ses activités.
L'un de ses collaborateurs,
Iouri Dmitriev,
est envoyé dans un camp
sous des prétextes fallacieux.
Propos en russe
Tout cela,
sur fond de répression généralisée.
Des opposants,
comme Anna Politkovskaïa
et Boris Nemtsov,
ont été assassinés.
D'autres ont été contraints
à l'immigration
ou sont derrière les barreaux,
comme Alexeï Navalny,
condamné
à 19 ans de camp.
L'homme crie.
En février 2022,
quatre jours
après l'invasion russe en Ukraine,
la Cour Suprême à Moscou
prononce
la dissolution de Memorial,
co-lauréate
du prix Nobel de la paix.
Motif : Memorial a
"créé une image mensongère
"de l'URSS en la présentant
comme un Etat terroriste".
-L'association Memorial
a été fermée.
Le centre Sakharov
a été fermé.
Leurs énormes archives
ont été cachées,
on les a sauvées
comme on a pu.
Dmitriev, qui avait
mis au jour des charniers
de l'époque stalinienne,
est en prison,
c'est-à-dire que le vrai travail
sur ce passé
est devenu un crime
puni par la loi.
-Eh bien, l'ennemi numéro 1
de Poutine, c'est Memorial.
C'est ceux qui documentent
les crimes du stalinisme.
L'ennemi numéro 1 de Poutine,
c'est ceux qui poursuivent l'oeuvre
de "L'archipel du goulag".
Memorial, c'est l'organisation
qui doit être détruite
pour que le grand projet totalitaire
de Poutine puisse avoir lieu.
Memorial, c'est l'esprit
de Soljénitsyne
et de "L'archipel du goulag".
Aujourd'hui, quand il y a un procès
contre Memorial,
quand il y a la dissolution
de Memorial, en réalité,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
On brûle "L'archipel".
...
-Parfois,
on essaye de nier
l'ampleur de la Terreur,
de la minimiser,
mais en gros, le fait même
qu'il y ait eu la Terreur,
ça, personne ne le nie.
Aujourd'hui,
voilà à peu près...
le genre de réactions
assez répandues
que j'ai observées
lors de discussions
sur la Terreur :
"Eh bien, oui,
il y a eu la Terreur,
"et alors ?
"Il y a juste eu
"de 500 000
à 700 000 personnes
"exécutées pendant
la Grande Terreur, bon, et alors ?
"Il y a eu la liquidation
"de la classe paysanne,
bon, et alors ?
"A l'époque,
l'Etat était puissant."
Aujourd'hui,
des gens qui disent ça,
il y en a autant
que vous voulez.
Et dans ce sens, "L'archipel"
est impuissant contre ça,
contre ce rejet
des traditions humanistes
de la culture russe.
Musique de tension
...
-"L'archipel du goulag"
lui pose un problème particulier,
car il montre le rôle horrible,
négatif et destructeur
joué dans l'Histoire russe
par le KGB.
Poutine lui-même,
en tant que produit du KGB,
et son empire incarnent
une sorte de renouveau
du rôle du KGB en Russie.
Je peux donc imaginer
qu'il souhaite
que ce livre
ne soit pas lu.
Protestations
...
-Le temps des répressions
est revenu.
Mon ami Vladimir Kara-Mourza est
actuellement en prison
et a été condamné
à une peine de 25 ans.
Il a dit
et écrit
qu'il trouve un grand soutien
dans les livres de Soljénitsyne,
de Boukovski, de Siniavski
et même dans le mien.
-Lors de son procès,
Vladimir Kara-Mourza
lit ostensiblement
le livre de Soljénitsyne
"Le chêne et le veau".
Dans une interview,
il a confié :
"Cette année, j'ai lu ou relu
beaucoup de livres,
"j'ai pu enfin lire
'L'archipel du goulag' en entier
"et avec soin.
C'est un livre
"que tout le monde doit lire,
aujourd'hui."
-Ce livre est, aujourd'hui aussi,
contre le régime,
parce qu'il parle de l'homme
et d'un Etat terroriste,
du destin de l'homme
dans un Etat terroriste.
-Il y a quelque temps,
j'avais relu ce livre,
et puis je viens de le reprendre,
et j'ai pensé :
"Mon Dieu, c'est tout simplement
ce qui se passe maintenant.
"Ca commence avec l'arrestation,
et puis la suite..."
Chaque fois que je l'ouvre,
je vois que la force de ce livre
est intacte.
Musique pesante
...
-Chaque année,
des touristes se rendent
aux îles Solovki,
là où a été créé, en 1923,
le premier camp
du goulag.
...
La mémoire des prisonniers
y est toujours présente,
de ceux qui sont morts d'épuisement,
de ceux qui ont été fusillés
et jetés
dans une fosse commune.
...
Mais quel sens donner aujourd'hui
à cette mémoire,
celle de "L'archipel du goulag",
de plus en plus occultée ?
...
-Croire que cet archipel
est uniquement réservé
à l'Union soviétique
telle qu'elle l'a été
pendant 70 ans,
c'est évidemment réduire
"L'archipel du goulag"
à un pur et simple témoignage.
Il est témoignage,
mais il est beaucoup plus que cela.
Et donc, il est valable
pour la Russie d'aujourd'hui.
"Mutatis mutandis",
ce n'est pas la Russie stalinienne,
mais il y a des traits
qui sont communs.
Il est valable pour nous, en partie,
pour d'autres parties du monde,
c'est-à-dire
que c'est un grand livre
qui non seulement apporte
sa grande...
Enfin, son tsunami de vérités
au moment où il est écrit,
mais qui est encore valable
pour aujourd'hui et le restera.
-Ce que je dirais à quelqu'un
qui me pose la question :
"Pourquoi il faut
lire Soljénitsyne ?",
c'est que
ce que Soljénitsyne dénonce
existe encore.
Tant que cette violence existe
et que ce déni existe,
eh bien,
Soljénitsyne restera d'actualité.
Et donc,
si je conseille de le lire,
c'est pas juste
qu'il faut comprendre
l'importance du livre
à une époque donnée,
mais car cette époque
n'est pas encore révolue,
et qu'elle le sera jamais.
C'est ça qu'on apprend.
Et ça, c'est...
...incroyablement frustrant,
parce que ça veut dire que...
Le livre, il est puissant,
mais en fait,
faut le réécrire à chaque fois,
et c'est ça, son histoire.
-Cette histoire ne disparaîtra pas
avec celles et ceux qui l'ont vécue.
Une nouvelle génération
s'est emparée de cette mémoire.
Il parle en russe.
...
Yury Dud est
un jeune réalisateur russe.
En 2019, il est revenu
sur les lieux du goulag
pour en tirer "Kolyma,
lieu de naissance de notre peur".
Ce film documentaire
de plus de 2 heures, mis en ligne
sur sa chaîne YouTube,
a dépassé
les 28 millions de vues.
En 2022,
accusé par le Kremlin
d'être un agent de l'étranger,
Yury Dud a été contraint
de quitter la Russie.
Musique grave
...
"Tant qu'il n'existera pas
dans ce pays
"d'opinion publique indépendante,
"il n'existe aucune garantie
"que tout cet anéantissement
sans cause de millions d'hommes
"ne se répètera pas à nouveau,
"qu'il ne recommencera pas
n'importe quelle nuit,
"chaque nuit.
Cette nuit, tenez.
"Celle qui va suivre
la journée d'aujourd'hui."
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...